hello and welcome to daily with Doc my
name is Becca dukes and I am just
excited that you have decided to join us
in our community where we are sharing
information that's not only empowering
but freeing imagine a life with less
pain
fewer Pharmaceuticals if you're on
Pharmaceuticals and more Mobility or you
know what let's just support your body
to the best that it possibly can be
supported so you can live the best life
possible where you're at
so we're not all about helping sick
people we're also about helping people
that want to maintain their health
you're in a good place
you've made that decision to invest time
in yourself
to gain information and knowledge and we
are so thankful that you chose to do
that with us so here on daily with
doc.com you will find all of the replays
from previous presentations that we have
been doing previous broadcasts with Dr
Joel Wallach pharmacist Ben Fuchs and
many others
who just have added to my life and
helped me to be the best that I can be
after not looking forward to Growing Old
for many many years only seven years ago
so welcome to daily with Doc make sure
that you follow with us on Rumble
YouTube and Facebook look for critical
Health news we are part of the critical
Health newsletter team and I am very
proud to be a certified ballistic health
coach with the Institute of holistic
health so proud that I have come on
staff with them and I am part of their
student services management so join us
get more information about that at
coachwithbecca.com
we look forward to seeing you come join
us
daily withdoc.com Zoom no daily with Doc
zoom.com Monday through Friday from noon
to just before 1
Pacific time
Monday through Friday we'll see you
there